[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIC HAMON: Good morning.
Welcome to this incredibly
early Thursday morning slot.
We traded a lot of
favors to get this slot,
so it's really nice to see
so many of you out here.
For those of you as
well on the Livestream
and watching the
recording, thank you
for giving us your time as well.
My name is Dominic.
I'm an engineering manager
on the Google Play Console.
DOM ELLIOTT: My name
is also Dominic.
I'm product manager for
the Android App Bundle.
My fun fact is this is
the fifth Google I/O
I've worked on but the first
time I've presented a session,
so I am very excited to be here.
VITOR BACCETTI: And
my name is Vitor.
I'm a product manager
at Google Play
working on increasing your
app install success and update
rate.
PIERRE LECESNE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Pierre, and
I'm an engineering manager
on the Android App Bundle
and Dynamic Delivery.
DOMINIC HAMON: Great.
So the focus of this
session is going
to be to introduce you
to some of the tools
that you can use to optimize
your app size and boost
acquisitions.
We're going to split the
session into three parts.
First, I'm going to
talk a little bit
about the factors that
impact your app's install
success rate on Google Play.
Then I'm going to hand over
to my colleague, Vitor,
who's going to talk
about some of the work
that we do in the
background on Google Play
to help your install
success rate.
And then finally, we'll
hand over to Dom and Pierre,
who are going to walk through
what you can do on your side
to help your
install success rate
and the tooling that we have
that can support you in that.
So to set some
context, in 2018, we
delivered a hundred billion
installations to our users.
That's about 8 billion a month.
Now, that works out when we
look at the amount of data
as 22 exabytes of data.
That's a lot.
That's 22 trillion gigabytes.
And I know we're playing
big number bingo here,
so I want to try and bring
that back to something
more concrete.
So in 2005, the global
traffic on the internet
was 22 exabytes, and that's
the year that YouTube launched.
So we like to think of this,
that the Google Play app
distribution network
last year was the size
of the internet back in 2005.
So this is why we care
about the amount of data
that we end up
delivering to users.
Now, what drives your
install success rate?
There are millions of users
that come through the Play Store
looking for apps to install.
And they might be searching for
your app, they might see ads,
or they might get
a recommendation.
Either way, at some
point, they end up
on your app listing page.
They're going to
read the reviews,
they're going to look at
the screenshots, the videos,
your store listing,
and hopefully
they'll make the decision to
click that install button.
But that is not the
end of the story.
That is not an acquisition until
that app has been downloaded
and installed onto the device.
There is a lot that can happen
between those two steps.
Let's take a look
at some of them.
When we looked at
our data, we found
that 30% of the time,
that installation
doesn't fully complete.
So that means that
a third of the time
that a user decides
to install your app,
they don't end up with
it on your device.
So what happens?
And what can we do
to improve this?
Turns out, when we look into
it, that there are three
main reasons for this drop-off.
There's the internal
free space on the device,
there's the time it takes
to download the app,
and there's the cost
of the data involved.
I'm going to go into each
of these in more detail.
So first, space.
This is not just a problem
for emerging markets,
the internal free
storage on devices.
This is a problem that we see
across North America, Europe--
everywhere that we look.
And what we've
seen in our data is
that out of our over 2 billion
users, a third of them--
28%-- have less than one gig
of free internal free space.
Now, how does that
affect your users?
Well, when the user
tries to install an app,
the Play Store will
determine if there's
enough free space for that
installation on the device.
And if we determine
that there's not,
we won't download that app.
We won't waste the user's data.
What we will do though is
pop up an Uninstall Wizard
that encourages the user
to free up some space.
Now, it's possible that
the user won't be able to
or won't want to
remove some of the apps
that they have to make
room for your app.
And Vitor is going to talk a
little bit later on about some
of the improvements that
we've made to the Uninstall
Wizard and some of
the ramifications
that that can have.
The second issue is time.
Now, it's fairly
obvious, I think,
that the larger your
app download size,
the longer it takes
to download that app.
What may be slightly
less obvious
is how impatient
some of your users
might be with the time it takes.
And what we see is, the
larger the app download size,
the more potential
there is for the user
to cancel that download.
And similarly, the longer it
takes to download your app,
the more chance there is
that the user is either
going to have a
network error or is
going to move out of their
coverage and, in either case,
will end up erroring out and
not getting the download.
The third thing we
talked about is cost.
So we take for granted Wi-Fi
or practically unlimited data
plans, but that is not
the case for the majority
of our users around the world.
And the cost of their
data can be significant.
So when they try to
download your app,
when they see how much data it's
going to take to download it,
many of them will immediately
cancel that download.
So we have space, we have
time, and we have cost.
But we wanted to go
a little bit further
than just finding out why
things were not completing,
and we wanted to come
up with something
a little bit more quantifiable
to share with you today.
So we developed a model
that maps the size reduction
or increase of your app download
with the eventual install
success rate.
And what we found
out from our model
is that for every
three megs that you
can save on your
download size, you'll
get a 1% increase in
install success rate.
Or, to put it another way,
every feature that you
add to your app that increases
the size of the download
will have to be traded off with
the eventual acquisition loss.
So there's a few other ways
in which size can affect
your install success rate.
What I'd like to do
now is to hand over
to Vitor, who can talk
through some of the things
that we've been doing
in the background
and how that can help.
VITOR BACCETTI:
Thank you, Dominic.
So, great.
So let's start talking now
about how Google Play can help
you to make even better
performance and things
that we can do
automatically for you.
You may be wondering,
first, why were
we talking about
these things that are
automatic if it's automatic?
Well, we are talking about
this so that you as a developer
can have an end-to-end
view of the entire funnel
and, knowing that,
optimize your app
to work better within
this architecture.
And we will point out
a few different things
that we do that you can
actually work with and perform
even better.
So we will talk about
five features today.
We will start talking about
one for space, two for time,
and then two for cost.
Great.
So let's jump straight
ahead and talk about space.
As Dominic was saying,
space is a huge barrier.
So out of there, we
have 3 out of 10 users
that don't have a ton of space.
They only have
one gigabyte left.
So even if cost is not an issue,
even if time is not an issue,
we know that these
users might simply not
be able to install your
app, and that's a shame.
So what we do here
is we have a feature
called the Uninstall Wizard,
that you can see here
on the screen, that saves users
to help them to free up space,
show how much space
they need to free up,
and gives a few options.
We have actually improved this
feature quite a bit in 2019,
as measured by what we call
the recovery rate, which
is how many users are
able to use this dialogue
and actually proceed
to the installation.
What did we do?
One, we changed the UI so
that it's much easier to use.
So we highlight the
relevant information,
we highlight how much
space needs to be clear.
It's easier to select and
easy to find these apps,
and we have seen a big change in
performance as a result. Next,
we also changed the ranking
so that we highlight apps--
their large apps
that are not used--
and users can easily find
them, so success rate improves.
Why this matters-- one, as
this feature becomes better,
it helps you guys.
It's something that actually
becomes even more successful
when you get more installs.
Two, as to improve
this feature too,
large apps are more
likely to be uninstalled.
So that's actually something
that you should think about.
Because if your
app is larger, you
will suffer more
with uninstalls.
And as Dom and Pierre
will talk later,
there are a lot of
tools that we provide
for you that help you to monitor
this and understand how we can
actually make our apps smaller.
So now let's talk about time.
So time is an issue because
people are impatient.
People have a lot
of things going on.
People don't want to be waiting
at a screen for something
to load.
They want to just be playing
the game or using a new app.
And people can so--
that's just what happens.
What we can do here is we
can make the artifacts,
make the APKs smaller.
And we do that
using compression.
For new installs, we
automatically, on average,
make 10% reductions on the
size that was submitted to us,
and that's something
that's great.
It just helps you without
anything different.
And for updates, the improvement
is even more dramatic.
We use patching,
comparing the version that
is available on the device
versus the version that
is going to be downloaded.
And when we do that, we actually
reduce the total APK size
download by 85%.
So updates are much
smaller and much
more likely to be successful.
And one thing here that you can
do as a developer to help us
is related to uncompressed
native libraries.
Because of compression, if
the library is uncompressed,
our compression works better.
So we can make things
smaller and, especially, we
can make the updates smaller.
So talking about
native libraries,
this is something new that
we are announcing here today,
and we're really excited.
It's a feature that is being
used for Google Play Instant,
which is instant games.
So you may go to the
app listing page,
and you see a button
saying Try Now.
That button allows you to click
and easily play a game really
fast or use an app without
something different.
And in that situation,
Try Now, it's now.
You need to make
this really fast.
And this is really important
so that it's really small.
How we can do this--
we were looking at a few
options, and what we notice is,
apps actually have a
lot of shared content.
So on this slide here, you
can see a few different boxes.
You have gray boxes, which
are actually content that
is specific to each app.
So in the example, game A and
game B, they might be assets.
They might be sounds.
They're the things that
make the game unique.
Then you have these blue
boxes, which are a game engine.
A game engine is actually
something that a lot of people
use.
There are a few of them,
and some are very popular.
And they're pretty
much in a lot of games.
And why should we be downloading
this thing over and over
again if we may already have
something on the device?
Now, until recently, we
didn't do this, actually.
Everything was like a black box.
We really would, thus, know
that this same member download
game A, game B, without
knowing the difference
between this content
inside each APK.
What we could do
that is something
much different and
much more interesting
is we could tell that
this user is a gamer.
This user has Wi-Fi, so
data is not such a big issue
for these folks.
And then what we can do
is we prefetch a library,
and we keep it on a cache.
And then, when we go and
click on Try Now, what happens
is we download only the
specific game assets,
and we reassemble
the APK on the device
so that the download
size is much smaller,
and the user can jump into
the experience much faster.
In this pilot with
Instant Games,
we are seeing savings of
up to 40% in download size,
which is massive and should make
a huge difference in conversion
and engagement with these games.
So jumping now into cost.
So cost is something that is
really easy for us to forget.
Because, well, if we're
watching this on the Livestream
or if you're here
at I/O with Wi-Fi,
we don't think
about these things.
You are streaming
a lot of megabytes
and not really thinking about
how much are we consuming data.
But a lot of users
don't think like that,
and they have
limited data plans,
and they need to be very
careful with every megabyte.
This leads to different
behaviors in these markets.
One thing that people
do which is very popular
are peer-to-peer applications.
And you can find them
in the Play Store.
There are a bunch of them.
And how it works is you
have, for example, your phone
and a phone from
a friend, and you
create automatically
a Wi-Fi connection,
a local Wi-Fi connection,
and then transfer files
so that there's no cost,
and this works offline.
And this is something
that users love.
Well, people don't do this only
with files like music, videos,
and things like that.
They also do it with apps.
And there a lot of
problems with that.
Security, we don't know the
[INAUDIBLE] the provenance
of this, might know
if not compatible,
and that's actually
quite dangerous.
We actually solved this
problem by creating a new API
that was launched at the end of
last year to fix exactly this
and that P2P apps can integrate.
What it does is they
check the APK to make sure
that it's actually a Play APK.
Two, it actually makes
sure that this APK
is compatible with
this other device
so that the transfer just works.
And three, we also
make sure that we
add to the user library, so
updates, metrics for developers
like you guys.
You find everything
in the console later,
and that's great.
So that's something that is
new, and it's pretty exciting.
Then, the last thing,
we'll talk about cost.
This is a pilot that's coming
up soon in a few markets,
so you should hear
more about it,
which is a pilot in
partnership with local carriers
or local mobile operators.
How it works is a carrier
can offer mobile data
at no cost for downloads,
installs, browsing the stores,
clicking on screenshots,
and all these things.
So if the user is one of these
users that actually is really
worried about data,
this no longer
needs to be part
of the equation.
They can just be rest assured
that they can download this app
and enjoy something
that they didn't before
and have fun with
your app and games.
Thank you very much.
And now I'll pass
the word to Pierre,
who will talk about things
that you as a developer
can make to make your app
smaller and more efficient
and, in the end,
reach more users.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PIERRE LECESNE:
Thank you, Vitor.
So we've seen the importance of
reducing the size of your app,
since it directly correlates
with the number of users
that will install your app.
Also, the bigger your
app is, the more likely
it is to be uninstalled.
Now that we've seen how Google
helps serving smaller apps,
let's see what you
can do on your side
to also optimize the size.
So we'll do this in three steps.
First, we need to
agree on the metrics
you should use to measure
the size of your app.
Secondly, once you
know what to measure,
you need to know
how to measure it.
And we've got some new
reporting in the Play Console
to help you with that today.
And thirdly, with
tracking in place,
we're ready to take actions
and start optimizing
the size of your app.
And we have also some new
tools and best practices
to share with you today, which
will help you do just that.
OK.
So before we see how
to optimize your app,
let's talk about what
you should measure.
So you're hopefully convinced
by now that the size of your app
matters.
But what app size
are we talking about?
It's important to
note that there
are different types of sizes
you can measure for your app,
and not all have
the same importance.
There are, in
practice, three ways
to measure the size of your app.
We have the app upload
size, the app download size,
and the app size on device.
And I'm going to explain
each in a bit more details,
but I want to start with
a bit of a show of hands.
Raise your hand in
the audience if you
measure the size of
your app by looking
at the file size of the APK
you upload to the Play Console.
All right.
Almost everyone.
Yeah.
That's indeed quite
a common practice
because it's easy to do.
That's what we call
the app upload size,
because that's the size
on disk of the file
that you upload to
the Play Console.
It turns out it isn't such an
important metric because it's
not what your users will see.
It's neither the size
of what they download
nor what they see when they
look on the device at the disk
usage of your app.
What you should measure instead
is the app download size.
This is the optimized
size of the APKs
that the users download to
their devices over the wire.
The optimization is
performed by Google Play,
and the final size is
determined by multiple factors,
including the type
of compression
we're able to perform or the
patching we're able to do
from one version to another.
This is the size that users
see in the Play Store as well.
And you can now also see
it in the Play Console
as Dom will show you later.
App download size is a
really important size metric
to track because it's
directly correlated
to your install success rate.
So how can you measure it?
So some of you may already be
familiar with the APK Analyzer
in Android Studio, which already
gives you the possibility
to monitor the estimated
download size of your app.
It also shows you the download
size broken down by file,
so you can see where the
biggest files come from.
For developers
publishing app bundles,
the download size will vary
per device configuration
because each user is getting
a tailored version of the app
that depends on the
device configuration based
on that device and language.
If you've published
an app bundle before,
you may already be
familiar with Bundletool,
which is the tool generating
the APKs from the app bundle.
We added a comment
in Bundletool to help
you estimate the
download size of your app
for the various
device configurations.
Let's take a look
at how to use it.
So the comment is
called get-size.
And it outputs, in a
CSV format, the minimum
and the maximum download size
of your app across the range
of devices your app supports.
In this example, you can see
that my app's download size
ranges from 17.9 megabytes
to 22.6 megabytes,
depending on the
device configuration.
Well, can I say, it's
still quite a big range.
So how can we know
in more details
which devices get what size?
So we can break down the result
by various device dimensions,
and this is done through
the dimensions flag.
So here we ask to break down
the results by SDK version,
and we get a bit more details.
We get a breakdown
by SDK version.
We see in this example that
the download size of my app
is bigger on older versions
of Android, J and K,
and smaller on L and above.
That's because pre-L Google
Play doesn't generate language
splits, so all
languages are included
in the APK served to the user.
Now, we can get into
even more details.
We can break down
on more dimensions,
such as ABIs, screen
density, and even language.
If you do that, then that
will output a lot of rows.
But you will get
to see the download
sizes for each full
device configuration.
With this comment, you can
track the download side
of your app for every build of
your bundle for all your users
at the granularity you want.
All right.
So that was download size.
Today, we're introducing a
second important app size
metric--
the app size on device.
The app size on device
is the approximate size
of your app on a user's device.
And as you'll see,
it can be much more
than just the size of your APK.
After an app is opened,
the app size on device
can vary quite a lot,
depending on how it's used.
So for the purpose of
measuring the data,
we will focus on the
size at installation time
before the app is opened.
Size on device is important
to track because it is
a major factor in uninstalls.
Note that it doesn't include
the cache or the user data.
It's just the application size.
To try and understand better
why the size on device
differs from your
APK size, here's
a simplified diagram of
what happens when an APK is
installed on the device.
First, let's look
at the dex files.
Dex files get optimized
by the platform
during the installation
by a tool called dex2oat.
This optimization will make
your app run faster, but usually
at the cost of a big size.
The size of the optimized
dex can vary quite a lot
by device and by SDK version.
And as I mentioned
before, it will also
vary during the
life of your app,
depending how the app is used.
Second, the native libraries.
When you compress the native
libraries in your APK,
the Android platform
needs to uncompress
them, which takes additional
space on your user's devices.
Fortunately, you can avoid this
by leaving native libraries
uncompressed in your APK,
which allows the Android
platform to read them directly
from it without having
to extract them, and that's
available since SDK 22,
and you get this for free
with the Android App Bundle.
So all of this makes
for the total size
on device of your app.
OK.
So now we have seen
the two app size
metrics you should focus on.
Dom will now show you
how you can now track
these in the Play Console.
DOM ELLIOTT: Thanks, Pierre.
[APPLAUSE]
Pierre talked about
the size metrics
you should be tracking--
download size, which
is what's delivered
over the air to users,
and size on device, which
is the device storage needed
for your app.
Now I'm going to talk about
how you can track and analyze
the size data for your
apps in the Play Console,
and then we'll move on to
how you can actually work
to reduce the size of your app.
You can now track both
of these size metrics
on the Statistics page
in the Play Console.
Statistics reports are
highly customizable.
You can do things like
compare both size metrics
to each other, you can see
the sizes for different device
configurations, and you can
compare the size metrics
to your other app metrics, such
as installs and uninstalls.
So for example, you
could pinpoint the impact
of a sudden increase
in your app size
and how it's impacting
something like installs
in a country like India,
which is particularly
impacted by changes in size.
That's not all.
We're going a lot further
than the Statistics page.
Today, we're launching a
brand new report for app size
in the Play Console.
You'll find it under
Android Vitals, which
is where you can
find all of the data
to do with your app's
health and performance.
There's lots of new
data in the App Size
report for you and your
team, so let's take
a look in more detail.
You'll see two tabs for both
of the important metrics--
download size and
size on device.
At the top of the
tab, we'll show
you the size for your
latest production release
compared to a reference device.
And if you're using multi-APK
or the Android App Bundle,
we'll show a range of
sizes for different device
configurations.
You can also see how you're
doing compared to peers.
You can actually
go in and change
the peers to be more appropriate
apps to compare your size to.
This gives you a
target to work towards.
Because size is
important to users
and it impacts your
downstream metrics,
you're going to want to make
sure you're doing better
than your peers
as far as you can.
Being able to compare
yourself to peers
is a brand new
functionality we're adding
to the Play Console this year.
You can see another example
here for your app's rating.
It's very powerful.
You can select 8 to 12 peers
to compare yourself to,
and you'll see the median
value of the peer set
and the difference between
your app and your peers.
So back to app size.
The next section of the report
shows you two new metrics
relating to your users.
These metrics use
anonymized user data
from devices opted in
to sharing their data.
First, you'll see the
proportion of active devices
which have your app installed
but have low free device
storage.
You can think of these devices
as having a higher uninstall
risk than devices which have
plenty of device storage.
Secondly, you'll
see uninstalls which
are happening on devices
with low free device storage.
App size may have
been a deciding factor
in driving these uninstalls.
This is the first time we're
giving you additional insights
into what might be impacting
your uninstalls in the Play
Console.
Keeping your app size
optimized and obviously as
useful as possible can help
to reduce these uninstalls.
We'll start populating both
of these metrics in the coming
months.
Now, we also show you
a view of your app size
and how it's changing over time.
Being thoughtful in how
these changes happen
is important because it
can impact your installs
and uninstalls.
In this example, you can
see when the app first
switched to the Android
App Bundle and the size
savings that resulted.
If you're publishing
with an Android App
Bundle or multi-APK,
you can also
see the full range of
device configurations here.
The next section
of the report is
data you'll only see if you're
publishing with an Android App
Bundle.
We're able to perform a
more thorough analysis.
So we can actually show you a
breakdown of all the components
that make up your app size.
You can see how much
of your app is made up
of code, native libraries,
resources, assets, and so on.
The point of this chart
is to help you prioritize
what to focus on.
You can get a very
clear understanding
of the main contributors
to your app size.
And you can see how they
change from release to release.
We've been testing the new
report with developers,
and they tell us they're
really excited to get access
to this new data.
They look forward to being able
to sharing it with stakeholders
in the team so that they can
actually prioritize reducing
app size on their road maps.
So we've covered
the size metrics
and the new reporting which
helps you track your progress.
The next thing you
need to do is actually
work to reduce your app size.
So I'm going to pause and ask a
quick question around the room.
Raise your hand if
you're already publishing
with the Android App Bundle.
OK.
Quite a lot of you.
That's pretty good.
So that's great.
For those of you not
familiar with it,
I'll just give you a quick
intro to the features,
and then I'll tell you about
the new things that we've added.
So the Android App Bundle is
Android's official publishing
format we introduced last year.
It's open source, supported
in Android Studio, in Gradle,
in Buck.
And for games, it's already
supported in Unity and Cocos
Creator.
App switching gives you
an average reduction
in download size of 20%
compared to a universal APK.
And partners are seeing
up to 11% increase
in installs from
these size savings.
That's a huge impact from
a relatively simple switch.
Over 80,000 apps are using
App Bundles in production.
Late last year, we shared that
apps such as Airbnb and Twitter
are using the App Bundle.
Many new apps have started
using it in production
and are seeing
these size savings,
from Flipkart and
Netflix to Shazam,
and games like Clash of
Clans and Minions Rush.
Google Apps are switching, too.
This year, Chrome, Duo,
Google Photos, and others
have all switched and
are seeing size savings.
The number one feature request
we've had from many of you,
and some of you may
be eagerly awaiting,
is better testing tools
for the Android App Bundle.
So you can already publish App
Bundles to the testing tracks
and test them as normal,
but this takes time,
and the app has to be signed
with your production key.
Today we're introducing
a new feature
called Internal App Sharing.
It's different to
testing tracks.
It allows you to drag an app
bundle signed with a debug key
onto a web page
to generate a URL.
You simply tap that
URL on any device,
and you'll instantly install
the appropriate splits
for that device.
It's very, very quick
and very, very useful.
That's not all there is
to the Android App Bundle.
It sets you up for
the future as well.
Once you've switched, you're
able to take advantage
of modular app development.
This is great for engineering
velocity and build times,
and it also lets you customize
how you deliver features
to your users.
So dynamic features are
coming out of beta today
with some new delivery options.
You can deliver
features on demand
or you can deliver
features based
on conditions, like device
features, or countries,
or SDK version.
All developers can now
publish dynamic features
to production tracks and join
apps like Chrome, Facebook,
and Netflix, which have dynamic
features in production today.
With the Android
App Bundle, we're
moving away from the
idea of a monolithic app
where everything gets
sent to all of your users
at install time.
Instead, you can deliver a
lean, efficient app upfront
and you can customize
the experience
for different types of users.
There's a whole I/O session
later today just on this topic.
You can watch
What's New with App
Bundles in the amphitheater at
1:00 PM or watch it on YouTube
later, too.
OK.
Let's get back to
optimizing app size.
So on the same app size report
that I've been talking about,
the final section is a list of
recommended size optimizations
for your App Bundle.
When you use the App Bundle,
we do a thorough analysis
and we generate tailored
optimizations which
are appropriate from your app.
We also order them by the
expected size savings.
This will help you prioritize
exactly what to work on next.
I'm going to invite
Pierre back on stage
so he can talk about
some of the optimizations
that we are going
to start suggesting.
PIERRE LECESNE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So one well-known
optimization that
usually provides
significant size savings
you should be all
familiar with is
code magnification, through
R8 or ProGuard, for example.
If we detect you're
not using it,
we'll prompt you for
this recommendation.
Another thing we do is
scan your image assets
and tell you how much
size you could save
if you converted them to WebP.
WebP is an image format Google
developed a few years ago.
It has both lossless
and lossy compression.
And, on average, WebP images
are typically 25% to 34% smaller
than comparable jpegs.
Android studio
already has a tool
which allows you to convert
images to WebP in batch or one
by one, and you can then preview
the image conversion results
and tune the quality level when
choosing lossy compression.
All right.
So the next optimization
is extracting
rarely used libraries.
Sometimes your app makes
use of a library which
takes quite significant
space in an app
but is used only
rarely by your users.
By extracting this library in
an on-demand dynamic feature
in the app bundle and download
it only when the user needs it,
you can often reduce the
size of the initial download
by a few megabytes.
An example of such
library is card.io,
which is a library used
to scan credit cards.
Here you can see an app where
we've extracted the credit
card scanning flow in a separate
dynamic feature in the App
Bundle.
We download it when the user
needs to register their card,
and then we perform
the scanning.
Then we don't forget to
uninstall the dynamic feature
once it's used and no
longer necessary to free up
space on the user's device.
Similar to large libraries,
you can do the same thing
with large resources
and assets, too.
We'll help you identify the
large resources and assets
in your app by displaying
in the list of optimizations
the biggest ones and the
download size when you
expand the optimization tip.
One approach could be
to extract a large file
into a dynamic feature
and deliver it on demand
or uninstall it
when it's been used.
But also, depending on
the size or the file type,
there are other approaches
you can take, too.
For example, for
media files, you
could consider
streaming them instead.
So all these
optimization tips will
be available on
this App Size page,
and we are actively
working on adding more,
so check back regularly.
DOM ELLIOTT: All of
this is available today.
Go to the Google
Play Console, and you
can start seeing optimizations
for your latest release.
In the near future, we're going
to launch a size optimization
plugin for Android
Studio as well.
You'll be able to see
optimization suggestions
directly in your IDE.
And what's really
cool about this is you
can apply some of
the optimizations
in just a few clicks.
Delivering billions of
installs every month
is a huge responsibility
and something at Play
that we keep on
working on to improve.
We work behind the scenes
to optimize every step
of discovery and distribution.
We're continuing to build
tools to help you publish
more efficient apps,
which can take advantage
of next generation
delivery options.
These are your
takeaways for today.
Number one, start publishing
with the Android App Bundle.
Number two, visit the new app
size report to track your data
and get new optimizations.
And number three, you can start
thinking about taking advantage
of modular app development.
The final thing we're going
to leave you with is a video.
[INAUDIBLE] is a developer of
many popular apps in India,
and they've shared their story
with us of how they switched
to the Android App Bundle.
So thanks very much, everyone,
and have a great I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]